Film Courage: I know we touched on some of this
previously. I'm wondering if you could
just go back to the hardest year for you
as a filmmaker and why? And then the
easiest year for you as a filmmaker and
what was your what was the outcome of
your thought after experiencing both
years? Kenneth Castillo, Filmmaker: Wow! Those were back-to-back the
worst year and my best year were
back-to-back and some I mean try to give
you the cliff notes but like 2010 like I
mentioned earlier starting with my son
getting in an accident I was getting
ready to get ready to shoot my third
film and you know on the day after his
accident basically I literally had set
my script to my producer that morning
the morning my son was in his was
injured so my assistant director was
already scheduling things and and and
getting things you know starting our
prep and I was supposed to shoot that in
February so you know they were calling
me she was calling me and people were
calling I wasn't answering my phone
obviously my son was my number one
priority and when I got on like where
the hell are you we got this fit we have
questions about this that in the other
and I called him I said my son was in an
accident he's in ICU and I don't I just
don't have any answers for you you have
my script you paid me for it if you want
if you guys got to stay with that
schedule just do whatever you want with
it
get another director I don't care and my
producer at the time was knew my family
so he was just like don't worry about
anything we're ready when you are then
they had that you know they had a deal
with blockbuster so they had to get
movies out at certain times he's like
well we'll figure it out he said just
don't worry about the movie take care of
your family and just you know keep us
posted on how Julian's doing and that
just made me feel good from a producer
to saying that because I wouldn't I
wouldn't have faulted them if he had
just said you know what we're gonna hire
another director because we have a
schedule but you know of course you know
stay with your son so it wasn't till
like three weeks after that accident and
he got home that my wife said
make your movie he's fine and I said I
want to go anywhere really I just wanted
to be if my son she's like you you love
this script you put your heart and says
he's fine he's totally fine you know and
go make your movie so I called my
producer I said that's what's just
started on pre-production he's like
we're already there I said I go did you
hire director he's like nope we knew we
know you're coming back listen all right
so I went to shot my third film and I
edited in Mexico City when I got back I
got told that and this is the bad year
this I got told by an actor I was
working with that he's got his life
story produced he's a bipolar Golden
Gloves boxer who was an actor and he's
got the money from this these two
brothers that wanted to produce his film
and and then when I gotten back from
Mexico I was told by my producer we have
the money to do your your fourth sounds
like great what's their all get started
so I started not bartending as much
because I was working so heavily on two
scripts at the same time which I don't
necessarily suggest but they were what
was great about that is when I would
submit an idea for one of the scripts
they would come back from producers they
didn't like the scene I would take that
scene and put it from my other script so
I was able to take mix and match them a
little bit that was a great time but
then at the end of that process like I
was ready I was like okay good let's go
I was wanting to quit my job I wanted
the the financing for both these to go
through and then it was there's some
skepticism and then blockbuster went out
of business and that just killed the
fourth the budget for the fourth film so
I was like okay I still have
counterpunch and then those two punks
there were producers decided that they
were gonna use my connections to do
their thing and they didn't want to
produce our thing anymore they were
gonna do their own thing and they end up
doing some stereotypical really crappy
horror thing that they did so I was just
like left holding this bag and I'm like
and I'm like two months behind on our
mortgage and I'm like I've got to get
back to work so I just threw those both
you know in a bin and I was
work and I was just like picking up
shifts left in Ryan's working five six
shifts a week and I just was not making
enough money because it was the economy
turn around at that time and I just
couldn't catch up I couldn't catch up
man and I just
by the time December rolled around I was
ready to premiere my third my third
feature film it was very ironic because
that Raley studios and it was probably
the week before that is very it's very
strange when you're doing your dream but
you're your life is kind of going south
right but this is going it was it's this
weird tug-of-war and I just remember
after telling my wife look I messed up
we're losing the house we're gonna have
to move
I don't know how aggressive they are
gonna be at coming to take the house my
biggest fear was coming home and there
being a locket picking up my kids and
there being a lock on our front door and
we can't get into our house I guess
we're gonna have to move right after
this shoot right after this the
screening and she was so gracious about
it and I remember sitting outside going
I'm screening my third feature film next
week and I'm losing my house how did I
even get here and I remember
going to Raleigh studios to test out I was
basically at that point thing and I'm
gonna stop after the third one I'm gonna
stop I've given up so much and
sacrificed so much after this third one
I'm done and I remember going to rally
studios and I was gonna do a test of my
hard drive because Louie was on the hard
drive and the projectionist was there
and you know these guys they do this
this is their job they've seen a million
filmmakers come in and they could care
less he just wants to get in and out
we're gonna do it we're gonna do a test
I'm gonna go to every ten minutes to see
if it's okay I'm like okay cool I go I
just have a concern about the first ten
minutes here and then we'll jump he's
like all right so go ahead and sit down
you can call me so I'm sitting in this
Raliegh's studio screening watching my
movie up there and I'm like this first
time I'm seen on the big screen I've
edited a million times on the small
screen
but all of it was just so big and the
nuance and the performances and it was
there and I'm just like watching it
going wow I'm watching it for the first
time by myself at Raleigh Studios and
before I knew it I'm like two-thirds the
way through and I haven't heard from the
projectionists and I'm like oh darn I
only have like a half hour to really be
there I only have a half-hour time to
test my movie so I turn around and he's
like four rows behind me watching the
movie and I can I go like this to him
and he's like don't worry about don't
worry about he starts he's watching my
movie he got into my movie and I just
was like it was a just a great moment
and it's such a target time for me and I
remember going to him going and we
watched the whole thing so me and him
watched all things like loved it loved
it is I see so much stuff come in here
man with he's always your budget on that
and I told him and he's like no way no
way
he saw I'm gonna keep my eye on you I go
thanks so much man and and then you know
we had the screening it was a great
screening and it got distribution and
that again it wasn't enough money by
that time I had I was already gotten
another apartment we were moving out so
2010 ended with us losing our house and
moving and you know having movies out I
was still doing shorts I'm still writing
I was still doing all those things so
then when we moved out I was pretty much
done with filmmaking I basically said
this is too much of a sacrifice that I
put on my family if it was just me who
cares right but you have a tough
conversation with my wife and kids
and 2010 sorry 2020 oh yeah so we get
the 2011 and it wasn't dire we weren't
homeless you know we I I had three it
was actually a really good lesson in
negotiation particularly if I come
against producers or distributors again
but I had three real estate agents that
were like hawks, like rats trying to get
our house and so I basically I emailed
them individually saying I have five
other real estate agents that are
offering me this amount of money to move
out in three weeks whichever one of you
comes with the
with the highest number is the one
that's going to get this house because I
had to sign off on on giving it to them
and so I got a good chunk of money to
have a little bit of a nest day you know
I was broke and my credit was shot
everything was shot get us into a nice
apartment and then start over
sorry just real quick how did they know
that they must have checked the bank
records yeah okay it's a whole racket
man it's a whole racket the banks were
never going to narrow no intention of
helping people keep stay in their homes
because it would have been very easy to
do so I I was like January February of
2011 now and I'm done done my family's
safe we're in a nice place on a balcony
I'm reading a book
my producer calls I'm like what does he
want hey what's up hey man fourth
feature is on we got some money we're
gonna go forward I go no no I'm not
doing it and he's like what do you mean
you're not doing it he's like we loved
your script we're gonna go forward to
shoot Mexico I said no no I'm not doing
it he's like well I go what's the budget
and the budget was just ridiculously low
I go my film can't be shot for that he's
like we'll make it happen man he they
were looking out for their company they
want to stay relevant I go let me write
something else that's smaller no we can
make it we can do it we can do it and I
said alright alright let's do it and so
then it was just hard to cast because
the budget was so low but I was felt
like okay here's my second shot right
I'd have to worry about money at this
point we had money in the bank we were
safe I'm gonna go make another movie I
thought my career was done that was a
bad motivation to go make that movie
because I pulled in some really great
cast and I just didn't do right by them
and that film even though I loved the
process of it it was still compromising
too much for the budget but we did it
and at the end of that I was in Mexico
on our last two nights of shooting
and the producer for the counterpunch
project calls me says where are you I
said in Mexico he's like I got the
funding for counterpunch now you need to
come and interview with these producers
because they're interviewing directors
from CAA and William Morris and you know
all the big agencies and I'm like no
that's my movie man I wrote it like
they're gonna pay for the script but
they don't want you to direct it well
that's nonsense and he says well when
can you get here I go I wrap in two days
I'll be there in two days and I go set
up a meeting for Monday I get back on
Sunday he's like okay so I tell my
editor who was with me on set at the
time because he was cutting the movie as
I was shooting that was my normal
process I love to do that haven't had
the luxury of doing that so I said I
told my editor
okay stop what you're doing he's like
what I go stop editing I need you to cut
me a trailer he's like why I go because
our next gig is going to be based on how
good that trailer is he's all serious I
said yeah I go you're coming with me on
that one
I go but I need you to cut it you have
24 hours he's like okay so he's like
cutting the trailer and he's not working
on the movie so my producer on that film
is telling me why isn't the editor
working on the movie he's working on a
trailer already I go well I like the
cast to see what you know how the things
coming together and so they feel good
about what we're doing and he's like you
have what we're losing time and money
and I said yeah I know but just let it
let us so he's almost done just let me
finish the trailer and then he'll get
back to editing so okay cool so he
spends like two days on this trailer and
my producers mad and we get into the
room and he's I need to have a meeting
with you I go okay just a second I bring
the whole cast in we have we own this
we're in this hotel then bring all the
whole cast and crew in there I know
Steven play the train trailer plays a
trailer and everyone just loses it a
trailer just nails everything I'm trying
to do with this movie and my producer is
very happy so he's like okay no worries
so I get back on Monday I have that
trailer with me and the producer she's
Hungarian very tough this is a dear
friend of mine now it's a very tough
Hungarian woman and I'm sitting inside
and she's like so why do i why am i
meeting with you you're not with CAA
you're not with William Morris you're
not with this you know that why am I
even talking to you we're gonna pay you
as a writer why do
think you should direct this and I said
well I just shot this film I got back
from I'd love ready to see the trailer
of it wait I mean you just shot it I go
I just wrapped it yesterday she's like
yesterday Sunday I said yes and you have
a trailer already I said yes let me see
it's a turn around she's watching the
trailer and I just sir she had folds my
laptop down she looks at me she's like
okay I go thank you appreciate your time
and she had another partner actually and
then she called me and said I needed to
speak to my partner first I said sure no
problem it was like a five-minute
conversation after that and I got that
gig so I got that right after I got back
from so I was in post-production on my
fourth and in pre-production on my fifth
and that was my best year man it was
just moviemaking non-stop and yeah it
was great and that the fifth one they
both got distribution the fifth one got
picked up by Lionsgate and was on
Netflix it's actually I just got word
that it's making its China debut this
movie came out five years ago it's
making its China debut in October and
it's UK debut just last month so that
movie is still got legs it's a boxing
film it's a genre film so those films
kind of they can go a little bit they go
longer they have a long shelf life so
that was my my worst and best years back
to back and those two in themselves
would be a book but I managed to keep
them to two chapters two very long
chapters but what was your takeaway of
all that like just from having those
back to back I didn't have time to think
about anything you know am i I just
didn't have time to think about it I
just felt like I've been through the
worst of it and I got two more
opportunities to do something and then
of course after counterpunch we screen
counter plans for my producers from the
fourth we're like now we got something
do you have something for year six I
said yes and and then shot that one in
March of 2012 you know so
it's all started kind of that those
relationships started because I was
building something with them at least I
thought I was building something with
them which was the troupe of actors and
everything else and then it just started
to rot from the inside out and I had to
walk away from all of that everything I
had built because people had cheapened
the entire thing for their own gain and
for their own narcissism and so since
then you know I'm gonna start it over
that's when I started marigold and
marigold was like I'm gonna do something
that nobody can copy but some people
tried to copy that as well so but that
movie hasn't I haven't put that one out
there as much because I don't need to
I'm gonna wait until I can I can put it
somewhere where people will see it and
no hurry I've got other things I'm
writing I have six films out there I
have an incredible reel
I don't need to just put it out there
just to put it out there I love it too
much to just stream it on Amazon for you
know what it you know anybody can do
that that's not distribution you know I
want it on Netflix that's where I want
it I'm not even looking at a theatrical
I'm looking at just Netflix you know so
I'm I hang on to it when did you start
writing it which one marigold I didn't
write anything it's completely untrue
okay yeah I mean that one I would say is
not lying out line I would come up with
scenarios and characters and I would
communicate those things to the actors
but they didn't have a script it's
improv oh yeah so I I prefer unscripted
only because it sounds like there wasn't
a plan there was a plan and there was a
vision we just weren't confined to
dialogue and it was really a tenuous job
for my editor and she was a new editor
that I found I loved her
because she found the story and she
crafted the story and stayed with she
stayed with me with that movie for a
good two years and now she's working on
bigger and better things so I'm real
excited for her as well so I'm a
training ground for people who are going
to move on to bigger and better things
you